هذه هي الطريقة التي يوقف بها الجيش الأوكراني تقدم روسيا باستخدام أسلحة مضادة للطائرات
مثل اللدغة المصنوعة في الولايات المتحدة ضد
طائرات الهليكوبتر التي تحلق على ارتفاع منخفض.
-300
أنت تعرف نوع أنظمة الدفاع التي
نحتاجها من طراز 300s وأنظمة أخرى مماثلة ،
تعرف إلى أي مدى يعتمد على
ساحة المعركة على قدرة روسيا على استخدام
الطائرات
بعد خطاب زالينسكي الحماسي أمام
رئيس الكونجرس بايدن الذي أعلن عن
حزمة مساعدة أمنية جديدة ضخمة
بقيمة 800 مليون دولار
بما في ذلك طائرات بدون طيار وأسلحة مضادة للدبابات و
20 مليون طلقة ذخيرة
تتضمن 800 نظام مضاد للطائرات
للتأكد من أن الجيش الأوكراني
يمكنه الاستمرار في إيقاف
الطائرات والمروحيات التي كانت
تهاجم شعبها والدفاع عن مجالنا
الجوي الأوكراني
على الرغم من كونها
كانت القوات الأوكرانية التي تفوق عليها تسليحها بشكل كبير تضع شكلًا
صعبًا  القوات البرية للبلاد بقيادة
العقيد الجنرال ألكسندر سيرسكي ،
وهو من قدامى المحاربين في الدفاع
الأوكراني عن منطقة دونباس ، وفي الوقت نفسه
القائد العام للقوات المسلحة الجنرال
فاليري زالوزني الذي يُنسب إليه الفضل على نطاق واسع في
إصلاح الجيش الأوكراني
يتعهد بمحاربة الروس حتى آخر
قطرة دم.
ليس عندك أي أوهام ولا
تنتظر هدية من الله يقول أنا
قاتلت وأعد قواتي المسلحة.
الأسلحة التي قدمتها الولايات
المتحدة وحلفاؤها تمنحهم فرصة قتالية.
الوحدات الأوكرانية تفجير الدبابات الروسية
بالكتف  - صواريخ مثل
الرمح التي قدمتها الولايات المتحدة أو أصهارها ، وهي
سلاح مماثل مضاد للدبابات مصنوع في بريطانيا ،
نحن في نقطة حاسمة في المعركة
هنا حيث تعمل
أوكرانيا على تغيير التوازن ضد
روسيا ، ومن الواضح أن روسيا في ورطة
تواجهها القوات الأوكرانية  قاتل
بضراوة مع الدبابات الروسية على الأرض
على الرغم من تفوق
جيش فلاديمير بوتين عليه بشكل كبير في حين أن الولايات المتحدة وحلف
الناتو لا يزالان يرفضان الفكرة.  منطقة حظر طيران
أوضحت إدارة بايدن
أنها ستستمر في تسليح
قوات كييف للمساعدة في تعويق
الجيش الروسي
وإلحاق خسائر فادحة.